[Music]
in quit-smoking
news yeah cut it out stop it submitted
by a Cinnabon oh that's my [ __ ] favor
in a bomb oh yeah his bomb is glazed
over everything
hey Japanese company is giving six extra
days off per year to non-smokers that's
pretty good Wow he's so easy for me
that's positive reinforcement that's
some new [ __ ] something new something
more positive you know recently when I
went to Japan people aren't smoke
there's like smoke free cities now
cities yeah yeah like remember [ __ ] was
it Shibuya or something like that but
the whole entire city is a smoke-free
zone you can only smoke in designated
areas and you know how everyone over
there follows the rules and [ __ ] so like
when I went there
no one was smoking like on the street
and you just see a [ __ ] pile of
people right by the smoking zone I was
like what the [ __ ] yeah dude Korea would
they would burn that whole city down if
they told me they can't smoke we create
people happen people smoke inside what
the restaurants do while eating they put
their [ __ ] cigarette in their baby's
mouth to hold an issue we went to some
places that that had indoor smoking like
some yakitori places and all that but I
think they're really pushing toward no
smoking no pushing it because of the
Olympics so they're trying to push for
like a healthier Olympic there's no
correlation whatsoever well because
they're gonna be the hosting city so
then if a states are only one be
reasonable it comes off more
health-conscious I did every every city
wants to put on their best front -
welcome - and big game but you know
China hosted this I don't know how much
more you gotta go hard even China put in
their best foot - because when they got
okayed for there was it 2009 so 2008
right so I went there 2005 2006 and all
of Beijing was like in a rush to build
they were like all these skyscrapers
that were half built because they wanted
to show the world what a
cool CDs are like no snot blowing signs
and like no peeing outside about that
but so a marketing firm in Japan is
giving its employees reason to quit
smoking and so they're saying that they
are offering non-smokers six paid
vacation days per year if they do smoke
if they don't smoke mm-hmm and so the
Tokyo based company called Peola Inc and
they're saying that they decided to do
this after an employee put in the
suggestion box that smoking is a real
problem in the workforce because it
takes up a lot of time to go out and do
it smoking breaks and also a lot of
people die from second-hand smoking so
then that's when this company was like
that's a good idea
we should positively reinforce this and
give people vacation days that they're
not gonna be touching we're not just
stressed out the smokers and make them
want to smoke more like Japanese people
are so damn disciplined though there's
like I'm not gonna lose they're saying
that uh at least 30 employees have
already taken advantage of this bridge
why should the smoking really curb your
appetite yes no I used to smoke and it
would I was already a mom what are you
smoking for you piece of [ __ ] I smoked I
was never like a crazy like chain smoker
but I did smoke for like maybe like
three four years are you addicted to
anything right now
yeah Oh candy sure I guess I don't eat
it that much I kept your dad too yeah
cuz I can't really relate to the smoking
thing but since I'm addicted to food but
I also like days off I'm like [ __ ] can I
give up a doughnut or two for one day
off and I think logically I'm like I
could do it but then if someone brings a
box of doughnuts [ __ ] that's tough food
is such a weird thing to me I wish I
could be mindfully active about what I'm
eating but for example yesterday night I
already had dinner right
I was already stuff yeah I already had
dinner
right and I'm like I had dinner with Joe
and I was like oh I'm good and then went
to go record in the studio and then
without even thinking twice Z goes and
you want to get a burn on my shot down
after I already ate the burger I was
like wait I really did well what did you
know I had ramen and Gilda and Gilda you
know what I do though so I'm on a diet
right yeah and you guys saw me Jeremy
brought in portals the Cuban restaurant
pastry oh so what did that I got it and
I was like yes and then my guilt trip
then I was like who can I share this
thing with and I went to KCI like you
are part of us and take half and then
that way I only have half the guilt so
you ruined your friend it was pretty
delicious and when we broke it in half
you got the bigger piece I was like just
give me the smaller
see that's so dope though because before
it entered your mouth you already
thought about it mine hassle can resist
the temptation mine happens after I wake
up the next morning and if the deed has
already been done you know it's like
it's too late so I just sat there and I
was I didn't realize I already ate
dinner so I had double dinner so what
are you gonna do today then that's like
David has a regretful one-night stand
every night yeah that's exactly what
that's true yeah he wakes up who did I
sleep with yeah but it keeps happening
over and over you know here we have is
the opposite I it's like 9 p.m. I'm like
oh should I need anything today oh [ __ ]
damn what's that like do you have an
addiction stomach pain like something
that you're addicted to not eating
like is there something you do every
single day and if you don't do it it's
like you feel weird you feel incomplete
yeah yeah there's just I feel like I
live an addiction which one I think
maybe I just like go past like a couple
hours though like touching it at least I
like looking sure if someone said hey if
you don't pick up your phone or look at
your phone for one whole day or for one
week while you're at work
but you get one full day off do you
think I'm great bill do it oh [ __ ] it's
that crazy man like I'm good I'll just
work that day a whole week without my
phone while I'm at work
yeah that's be hard no and then is it
like 95 can a worker and jqe and that
not if I work well I'm gonna die I need
it for my breaks I kind of like I need
to be yeah you know what the thing is I
don't mean my phone though yeah I do it
because I have to be conscious of what
I'm but you need the food yeah that's me
because I think my doughnut is your
phone we're like let's say if I'm
working a nine-to-five job oh my [ __ ]
this place [ __ ] sucks but then the
minute I take a bite of that doughnut
and it's Krispy Kremes it's like an
escape from reality you're like racing
Rob that makes it funnier he's saying
normal action you guys didn't see this
this was off-camera but his neck is hurt
right and we just talked about this
there's a box of tissues right here and
he's good they needed a clear-cut mess -
yeah can you get past me the boss Oh his
neck sore so I pass it over to him right
I open up the bag of chips we'll put his
his wife out the way yeah six inches of
face and somehow he went through it
grab the chip when he could've easily
asked me for his neck name for me to
pass the chips and that's how much he
likes food there's no joke shit's real
out here man it's like you and your your
movie trailers if you can't watch a
movie trailer for a whole week for one
day of work it's not the same when you
watch the movie trailer in the new icon
that you know when a video gets uploaded
it says new on it if it's not new
anymore it's like I don't want to watch
it no more you want to be like the first
what's worse so being able to watch all
the movie trailers but not having time
to watch
the movie itself or not watching movie
trailers for the whole week but then now
you earn yourself that one day to
actually watch for movie theater in a
movie okay I'll go to the movie theater
there now to watch that when they pick
where they serve lobster rolls yeah some
beers what am I not every day is a
[ __ ] battle you know it's like I wake
up did you change your addictions to
like every couple of months yeah I mean
I think I'm interested into something
yeah or like I feel like when I get rid
of one another one surfaces it's like
hip hypnosis you know when you like oh
I'm gonna quit [ __ ] cigarettes or
whatever right but then now you're
addicted to gambling so it's it's
constantly rotating what's going on I
don't know the current one within
rotation right now I think maybe just
online gambling hmm yeah I like online
gambling and then uh tomorrow it might
be so but the thing is when it's healthy
addictions like I'll go through these
thins of life I [ __ ] love running
right now like I love running so much I
only want to eat like one meal a day and
all these things or whatever I wish I
could be addicted to running but then
there'll be other times where it's like
let me get stoned all day
[Laughter]
like you know sometimes I go through the
food stuff where I just want nothing but
the worst [ __ ] and it's like there's a
bag of chips being open I told myself
I'm gonna eat [ __ ] salad today but
I'm gonna eat those chips every day it's
like a different person with a different
addiction and I don't know I'm I'm
always blindsided so it's an interesting
with like food and like health though
because I feel like there's so much
knowledge out there in general like if
you're not going for a specific X
aesthetic or strength lose weight like
the knowledge is out yeah I just choose
to ignore like a [ __ ] you know I
mean like the knowledge is there's like
liquor
you probably shouldn't have three
dinners yeah I mean but your friends
want to go out who am I to deny their
joy eggs like this rationale happens
like make it work that [ __ ] off tomorrow
knowing damn well I will not there are
times - I watched the Rocky movies just
to motivate myself me worked out that's
a pre-workout like you have to watch it
for two hours bringing away oh [ __ ]
that's gonna be me I'm a [ __ ] workout
and then I wake up and I look about some
way to perfectly find the way you are
did I stop myself from doing anything
it's [ __ ] annoying man a toad
self-esteem is - sometimes I'm addicted
to reading and that's a good day that's
just like I need to read this [ __ ]
book then give me another book to read
oh yeah I don't wanna do anything but
reading and I think those are healthy
addictions
well they do get in the way of your
productivity but at least it doesn't
damage your health
[Music]